the UN Secretary General says he's
deeply troubled by the Israeli
government's decision to speed up the
construction of illegal settlements in
the occupied West Bank in a statement a
spokesman for Antonio Gutierrez said
that he's alarmed by the anticipated
advancement next week of over 4 000
settlement units he reiterated that
settlements are a flagrant violation of
international law he urged the Israeli
government to Halt and reverse these
decisions and to immediately and
completely cease all settlement
activities in the occupied Palestinian
territory let's bring in Khalid
al-ghindi he's a senior fellow at the
Middle East Institute he joins us via
Skype from Arlington Virginia uh Khalid
good to have you back with us so look
these are very strong words from the U.N
spokesperson on behalf of the Secretary
General reiterating that Israeli
settlements are a flagrant violation of
international law why do you think the
U.N is saying this now and how
significant is it
well it's saying it now because it
really has no choice uh the the actions
of this Israeli government they've
accelerated virtually every negative
Trend that you can imagine from the
violence on the ground to settlement
expansion to evictions to building and
uh you know expanding settlements in the
so-called doomsday settlements like E1
uh outside of Jerusalem so uh this is
really it I mean an attempt to uh to
slow down uh this very accelerated Pace
at which this extremist government is
working to to destroy chances for
whatever may be left of a two-state
solution yeah and that's an interesting
point you make hardly because the UN
Secretary General urged Israel again to
hold reverse settlement activity
um but the fact is Israel has ignored
these U.N calls in the past will these
calls make any difference now given that
Israel's coalition government is now
more right-wing than ever as you say
yeah I I think probably not I I think
unless the uh very strong words are
combined with some sort of action by key
players like the United States or the
European Union uh some sort of uh
consequence uh to these actions
um then they're simply going to be
ignored as they always have been uh so
there really needs to be uh action on
the ground uh to to back up these strong
words and we just haven't seen that
um at all and it was just a day or so
ago that Israel's far-right government
gave the finance ministry sweeping new
powers to bypass settlement planning
regulations that I think had been in
place for nearly 30 years or so so what
is this telling us Holly about the
future of illegal Israeli settlements
but with what it's telling us in very
clear terms is that settlements are not
going anywhere Israel has no intention
of evacuating or dismantling any
settlements and in fact they're going to
step up the pace of uh of building
um and and expanding those settlements
um what is what is different about this
uh this transfer of powers to this uh uh
um to the Minister of Finance is that
it's taken the settlement Enterprise out
of the hands of the military as the
occupying power uh and into civilian
hands which is something that that sort
of crosses the threshold between merely
de facto annexation to something more
like de jure annexation and it's it's
precisely the sort of thing that the
Biden Administration and the Europeans
have warned Israel not to do uh and yet
they've done so anyway uh but we've not
seen any real uh consequences let me get
a final thought from you Khalid um and
touch on the issue of the two-state
solution the U.N says Israeli settlement
expansion undermines the viability of
the two-state solution in any future
peace agreement but many observers say
the two-state solution is dead in the
water anyway so so does there need to be
a recognition that the two-state
solution may not be viable going forward
and if that's the case what is the
alternative
well currently there isn't a a
politically viable alternative to the
two-state solution
um unfortunately the two-state solution
itself is looking like it is not uh
politically viable either I mean if only
because the current Israeli government
as well as the previous one had no
interest uh in in uh in pursuing that
and in fact is working against it
um the the reality is that the the this
International stakeholders do need to
start considering the possibility of
Alternatives that like a one-state
solution with equal rights uh some sort
of Confederation between Israel and
Palestine but they need to go beyond uh
the the rhetoric about supporting a
two-state solution without actually
doing anything to move in that direction
really good to get your thoughts and
your analysis thank you very much indeed
so for talking to other thank you
thank you
well meanwhile tensions are high in the
occupied West Bank after an Israeli
attack on the Janine refugee camp at
least five Palestinians were killed in
the early morning assault a child is
among the dead Israeli forces say they
enter the camp to arrest two suspects
but the fighting raged for hours with
Israeli military gunship helicopters
opening fire on the occupied West Bank
for the first time in decades neither
Ibrahim reports from Janine
this is the moment that turned an
Israeli arrest trade into a 10-hour
gunfight
Palestinian homemade explosives damaging
armored vehicles in the Janine refugee
camp and injuring eight Israeli soldiers
took Israeli forces nearly one hour to
move the soldiers to hospitals and hours
more to pull out at least five vehicles
Muhammad bramkis as the camp felt like a
battlefield
the Army was in the houses of my
neighbor and my father an Israeli
military jeep was near my car here you
can see the damage they were lined up in
the street it was very scary
Palestinian casualties
rare for Israeli forces
this is the first time in nearly 20
years that we see Israeli helicopters
strike Palestinian targets here in the
occupied West Bank people here say that
scenes today resemble the battle that
took place in the refugee camp in 2002.
shortly after the Israeli forces
withdrew Palestinians buried they're
dead
among the five Palestinians killed is 15
year old Ahmed
any time I asked him for something he
always said yes he was decent polite
respectful but his problem was that the
moment the Israeli Army raided he ran
towards them he wanted to die after his
friend Omar was killed the death of his
friend was very painful for him
's 31 year old son was shot while
fighting against Israeli forces
they're the ones attacking us if they
didn't come over none of this would have
happened
shot this video from one of the rooftops
near the camp
us cameraman has a master was shot in
the side while wearing his press gear
they shot me four to five times and even
as I was rushing to the ambulance they
kept shooting at me
Israeli forces have been raiding Janine
and nablis for more than a year now they
say it's to crack down on fighting
groups
but many Palestinians say they're proud
that the limited weapons can put up such
resistance against one of the most
advanced armies in the world
the occupied West Bank
elsewhere in the occupied West Bank the
Palestinian Health Ministry says a 20
year old man has died of his wounds
after being shot by Israeli soldiers on
Monday it happened in Hassan near
Bethlehem Muhammad Zakaria al-zaul was
shot in the head during clashes with
Israeli forces who were raiding the area
he later died in hospital